je pense
et nous nous retrouvons aujourd'hui pour
la deuxième audition de la journée pour
entendre intercommunalité de France avec
Monsieur Patrice Verchère qui est membre
du conseil d'administration de
l'association et vous êtes président de
la Communauté d'Agglomération de l'Ouest
trop Damien
merci merci Monsieur Verchères de votre
présence et de celle de votre
association on ne peut bien sûr évoquer
l'avenir des communes et des maires sans
prendre en compte le point de vue des
intercommunalités qui leur permettent
d'inscrire leur action dans une échelle
plus large et leur fournissent des
moyens supérieurs aujourd'hui le
phénomène intercommunal est arrivé à
maturité et il est nullement question de
le remettre en cause pour autant les
auditions et les déplacements que nous
avons tenus nous confirme dans l'idée
qu'il est toujours nécessaire de
s'interroger sur le bon équilibre au
sein du bloc communal qui permet à la
mutualisation intercommunale de jouer
pleinement son rôle en faveur des
communes sans privé ces dernières
démarches de manœuvre qui donne tout son
sens à l'action locale et avant de vous
donner la parole pour nous présenter
votre point de vue et le point de vue de
votre association intercommunalité de
France notre rapporteur aura peut-être
petit préalable à vous donner
merci la présidente merci à vous et
merci cher Patrice de cette présence
aujourd'hui je vais pas allonger le
propos et l'idée c'est surtout de vous
entendre avec notamment cette aspect de
notre mission qui tient bien sûr
à prendre en compte la vie des
intercommunalités puisque sans
réinterroger le le modèle qui est celui
du de l'organisation du bloc communal et
donc de la nécessité d'avoir une
intercommunalité qui est cet espace
nécessaire de projet de mutualisation
sur sur nos territoires on a quand même
quelques quelques mers qui j'allais dire
nous interroge sur notamment
le lien entre commune intercommunalité
et parfois on a pas
dans tous les territoires de France mais
sur certains territoires que nous avons
visité notamment ceux des territoires
qui ont des fameuses intercommunalités
que l'on a appelé communément XXL le
sentiment des fois d'avoir une voix qui
peut moins porter
s'inscrivant dans un concert de communes
ou parfois ceux-ci on le on le sentiment
plutôt de subir que d'être que d'être
acteur quand bien même il considère
l'intercommunalité comme une comme une
nécessité
le sujet bien sûr et pour nous pour nous
important parce que nous essayons
d'identifier quels sont les causes
finalement de cette de cette
désaffection qui qui a trait nos
auditionnions tout à l'heure la
directrice générale des collectivités
locales des difficultés tiennent aussi
des difficultés entre les relations
entre pardon la commune et l'État avec
le le sentiment d'avoir des méandres et
une architecture de plus en plus
complexe pour pouvoir
avoir accès aux dotations de l'État
montage des dossiers à cette politique
d'appel à projet et c'est vrai qu'on a
le sentiment que la conjonction de tous
ces éléments est une source
supplémentaire de de démotivation
s'agissant de l'intercommunalité comme
je le disais il était important pour
nous d'avoir votre votre sentiment parce
qu'on sait depuis singulièrement depuis
la loi notre même si la loi RCT avait
jeté les les bases du nouvel
intercommunalité c'est vrai que depuis
la loi notre on a le sentiment d'un
renforcement de nouveaux périmètres et
que ce mandat finalement est le premier
mandat ou la loi à quelques exceptions
prêtes sur sur certaines compétences qui
ne seront intégrés que pour certains
types de d'intercommunalité à l'horizon
2026 on est dans le premier mandat
intercommunal avec une aussi forte et
donc on a
dans certains territoires encore une
fois la volonté peut-être de retisser un
lien ou de retrouver des modalités qui
permettent une expression qui soit la
plus large et qui prennent en compte
l'expression de de toutes les de toutes
les communes encore une fois bien sûr en
prenant en compte nécessaire
représentation démographique et voilà
nous souhaiterions un petit peu
connaître votre sentiment sur sur ces
sujets encore une fois convaincu de la
nécessité de conforter le le modèle qui
est celui du bloc communal et de
l'intercommunalité mais en prenant aussi
en compte les réflexions qui peuvent
nous remonter qui ont été formulés nous
avons essayé de parcourir
des territoires de France très
différents comme les Vosges les vilaines
la Haute-Garonne la Somme et organiser
beaucoup d'auditions justement pour
entendre la plupart des aides de France
sur l'ensemble des territoires
convaincus qu'il y a aussi et ça vaut
pour l'intercommunalité de plus en plus
un principe de différenciation
territoriale qui génère aussi quelques
quelques conséquences dès lors qu'on est
un territoire de montagne un territoire
de Plaine dans des territoires où les
régions sont plus ou moins importantes
convaincu aussi qu'il y a un lien
parfois fort avec avec
l'intercommunalité qui justement joue à
plein son rôle d'organisation parfois de
péréquation sur certains des des
territoires voilà en quelques en
quelques mots mais c'était plus un
propos introductif l'idée c'est d'avoir
un petit peu votre votre sentiment et
puisque j'ai eu l'occasion de poser la
question au président Martin il y a
quelques semaines lors d'une précédente
audition sur le groupe de travail
présidé par le président RC sur la
décentralisation puisqu'on avait vu que
le président Martin souhaite que
l'intercommunalité
petit à petit peu ouprou devienne une
strate de collectivité quel est votre
votre regard parce que et j'en finirai
par là il y a aussi un sujet qu'on ne
peut éluder on a aujourd'hui les tenants
d'une désignation des conseillers
communautaires au suffrage universel
direct c'est une question que certains
ont évoqué
vous connaissez notre notre position
là-dessus mais en tout état de cause
c'est un sujet qui qui se pose alors
Patrice est un élu du sol département de
France qui a une métropole en son sein
où les représentants sont élus au
suffrage universel direct il y a
effectivement un sujet qui qui nous
intéresse de près voilà je veux pas être
plus long je l'ai déjà été beaucoup trop
on passe la parole et puis bien sûr
pouvez à loisir et évoquer tous les
sujets qui vous semblent importants et
qui sont portés par par la DCF
merci beaucoup même la présidente
monsieur rapporteur très heureux de
participer à cette mission d'information
alors je voudrais excuser bien entendu
une autre président Sébastien Martin qui
m'a demandé de représenter
intercommunalité de France donc je vais
surtout parler des positions de
l'intercommunalité on a vu les questions
que vous souhaitiez que l'on aborde mais
aussi faire part de l'expérience je suis
un peu un cas à part puisque j'étais
parlementaire j'ai démissionné
volontairement pour redevenir maire et
présidente d'intercaux donc autant dire
que j'ai peut-être une façon d'aborder
les choses peut-être différemment que
certains élus qui c'est vrai regard du
but du poids de l'administration des
difficultés à exercer le mandat ont
parfois l'envie d'arrêter ou de passer à
autre chose donc c'est vrai pour le coup
j'ai un positionnement un peu différent
même si après cette période
parlementaire de redevenir mère me
permet de voir aussi quelques
changements en quelques années sur le
rôle du maire et et les conditions dans
lesquelles on peut l'exercer donc vous
le savez interco de France c'est près de
1000 intercommunalités sur l'ensemble du
territoire au même titre de ce que vous
avez dit tout à l'heure il y a les
petites intercommunalités jusqu'à
intercommunalité XXL d'où pour nous
parfois peut-être la difficulté de
trouver des points communs sur tous les
sujets puisque là aussi l'interco je
pense c'est construit également sur la
différenciation également sur la
possibilité des intercos bien de prendre
certaines compétences bien sûr non
obligatoires d'aller aussi sur
mutualisation
votre votre mission parle donc de
l'avenir de la commune et du maire
j'allais dire dans intercommunalité on a
la commune et on a le maire les deux
vont ensemble je vois pas comment
l'intercommunalité pourrait ça pourrait
peut-être répondre en partie à votre
question ne plus voir être le
représentant de la commune et le maire à
l'intérieur de jouer un rôle à
intercommunalité alors pour pour aller
tout de suite sur le sujet que vous avez
évoqué rien n'est tranché au niveau de
l'intercommunalité le président a une
position avec d'autres élus de
l'intercommunalité de France concernant
cette possibilité un jour peut-être des
intercoses de venir des collectivités
collectivités à part entière c'est loin
d'être tranché c'est un débat et je
pense que on se fait fort à interpréter
de France de débattre de tous les sujets
des sujets les plus faciles au plus
difficile
mais force est de constater
qu'aujourd'hui ce sujet est loin d'être
tranché il a été abordé notamment leur
du congrès à Bordeaux au mois d'octobre
je crois et on a bien vu que voilà
c'était un sujet qui qui va encore être
en discussion pendant quelques années
sur l'intercommunalité
je pense que l'intercommunalité un vrai
rôle à jouer auprès des mers
notamment pour les c’était différent
dans les intercommunalités XXL mais
l'intercommunalité la plupart du temps
varie entre 20 50 000 15000 habitants
10000 habitants et pour le coup
l'intercommunalité joue un vrai rôle de
soutien en mer doit jouer ce rôle si
elle le fait pas auprès des mers bien
sûr en assurant les compétences
obligatoires qui que les communes n'ont
plus les compétences non obligatoires
qui ont pu être prises mais aussi on
voit une évolution enfin moi j'ai pu le
constater je pense que c'est vrai sur
l'ensemble des intercos de France c'est
qu'on propose de plus en plus de
mutualiser un certain nombre de domaines
divers et variés suivant les secteurs je
pense qu'il y a pas de vérité et c'est
là toute la force aussi de
l'intercommunalité avec les communes ça
vient bien dans le pack de alternance
comment on aborde les sujets et quand
vous parliez que parfois ils peuvent
avoir des mers qui se sentent mal à
l'aise au sein de l'intercoeur ce que
peut-être pas assez
pris en compte notamment les maires
souvent des plus petites communes quand
l'interco est immense ou quand il y a
une commune qui impose quasiment au
regard du nombre d'habitants mais je
pense que au-delà de je suis pas sûr
qu'il faille toujours légiférer entre
guillemets il faut savoir laisser puis
je pense que le Sénat est une chambre la
Haute Assemblée je crois attentif à cela
il y a autant de façons de gérer qu'il y
a de président et généralement la
plupart du temps dans l'intercommunalité
les présidents cherchent à avoir
l'unanimité ou en tout cas une très
large majorité c'est comme ça qu'on
construit nos projets de territoire les
packs de gouvernance les packs financier
sur la mutualisation on voit bien que
sur plein de domaines les communes
notamment les plus petites qui qui
reflètent vraiment le territoire
national
les fondamentaux même de notre pays s'il
y avait pas l'interco il y a des choses
qu'elle ne seraient plus faire au passé
bien faire pourquoi parce que il est
difficile aujourd'hui de recruter des
secrétaires de mairies je crois qu'il y
a une mission également au Sénat sur le
sujet c'est un vrai sujet et l'interco a
un rôle à jouer en ce qui concerne mon
interco par exemple il y a des relations
très régulières entre le DGS de interco
50 000 habitants bon avec les DGA et les
sauvetats de mairies et les DGS des
communes les plus petites parce que on a
besoin de travailler ensemble d'apporter
des points de vue sur la gestion des
ressources humaines qu'on a mis en
commun en partie pour les communes les
plus importantes mais aussi sur les
domaines on voit le contentieux qui peut
arriver sur les appels d'offres bah là
aussi on propose de manière payante mais
pas très cher aux communes de faire de
monter les appels d'offres à leur place
par exemple on a sur également
l'informatique le cyber c'est pas la
commune même l'interco au sol est un peu
difficile l'intercose peut proposer
aussi de l'ingénierie au même titre que
les départements parfois c'est les
départements et l'interco l'interco est
vraiment
omniprésente auprès des communes et des
mers je vois pas je pense que quand on
voit et quand on écoute un petit peu les
maires qui qui sont un peu parfois usés
s'il n'y avait pas l'interco je pense ce
serait pire de mon point de vue et du
point de vue également de
l'intercommunalité de France l'intaccot
doit vraiment jouer ce rôle de faire en
commun ce que individuellement ne serait
pas faire c'est le but de l'interco et
c'est le but qui doit rester vraiment
mais en donnant de la souplesse qui a
été ce qui a essayé de faire la loi 3DS
et les évolutions législatives qui a eu
ces dernières années mais sur les
gouvernance qui est souvent reprochée je
pense que là vraiment ça vient vraiment
de l'exécutif et du président
il y a le bureau il y a la conférence
des maires
peut-être parce que je suis j'ai que 31
maires mais moi j'ai souhaité que tous
les maires soient au bureau
parce que il se décide beaucoup de
choses dans les bureaux
quand on dit il faut intéresser les
conseillers communautaires il y a allons
sur des sujets en conseil communautaire
qui vont intéresser et enlevons de ces
conseils communautaires des choses
pratiques qui doivent relever du bureau
pour aller un peu plus vite par exemple
c'est un exemple mais pour le coup le
bureau doit intégrer les maires alors
c'est vrai que sur les problèmes la
problématique c'est les interco XXL où
là il peut avoir 100 mères ou peut-être
même plus chez pas qu'elle est la plus
grosse intercommunalité de France mais
là ça peut poser problème parce qu'après
c'est vrai que ça devient aussi une
structure trop importante c'est pour ça
que de faire très gros c'est pas
forcément un gage d'efficacité notamment
pour les communes les plus petites je
crois qu'on a fait une avancée de
regrouper certaines inter-côtes c'est
plus ou moins bien placé suivant les
départements mais si je prends l'exemple
du département du Rhône il y a eu des
mariages plutôt raisonnables qui ont été
faits donc ça ça vient aussi souvent des
préfets puis après il y a la politique
qui rentre dedans on le sait bien mais
je pense que réellement il faut en ça
c'est ce que demande un tacot de France
d'éviter de de repartir encore sur un
chamboulement
de regroupement intercommunal ou un
chamboulement du cadre législatif des
interventions des intercos au même titre
que les maires ne veulent pas non plus
que ça que certaines choses bougent
constamment parce qu'au bout d'un moment
ça donne le fourni et et on passe un
temps fou avec une administration qui
est de plus en plus tétillonne
à gérer des législations et des
réglementations et des décrets qui sont
en cours d'écriture et donc suivant les
départements où on se trouve on a une
vraie difficulté là dessus mais en tout
cas l'intercommunalité doit jouer ce
rôle auprès des mères et et des communes
de France
je pense que je peux pas dire assez
d’unanimité mais il y a un vrai rôle et
beaucoup de présidents intercommunalités
sont maires
très souvent et on se rend compte que
quand des mères pour des raisons
politiques ne siègent pas à l'interco ça
pose problème à un moment ou un autre
parce que l'interco aujourd'hui a pris à
des compétences obligatoires mais plus
toutes les compétences plus
habitualisation si le maire n'est pas
membre du conseil communautaire à un
moment donné il y a quelque chose qui ne
fonctionnera pas entre les relations
entre sa commune et l'interco parce que
c'est les relations humaines tout
simplement qui rentrent en ligne de
compte
voilà ce que je pouvais dire après je
sais que vous avez quelques questions
plus simple puisque intéressant on se
retrouve beaucoup dans vos propos
je sais pas si Anne qui nous a rejoint
pour l'instant
peut-être quelques quelques réactions
aux propos que que l'on partage parce
que justement il correspond selon nous à
une position assez équilibrée qui
de par la nécessaire représentation des
élus et des mers tant qu'encore une fois
le cadre je veux dire n'a pas n'a pas
évolué mais la réponse a été faite sur
sur cette question là on est à peu près
de enfin on partage un esprit qui a été
d'ailleurs celui que nous avons essayé
de défendre dans la loi 3DS ou dans les
différents rapports convaincus qu'il
faut qu'il y ait à minima quel que soit
la philosophie partagée des évolutions
qui prennent en compte les réalités des
territoriales moi peut-être deux sujets
un sur lequel je me permets de revenir
quand même parce que effectivement ce
que l'on observe aujourd'hui très
clairement
c'est deux deux cas de figure
celle des intercommunalités qui ont une
gouvernance alors là je parle de façon
quantitative qui est alors le terme
raisonnable et pas nécessairement le
plus à propos mais dans lequel on arrive
à garder je veux dire une forme
dire de qui permet une certaine une
certaine proximité qui permet un échange
et le cas échéant qui peut même imaginer
laisser imaginer que chacun des mers
puisse être représentés ou sont
représentants être
sièges au sein du au sein du bureau de
l'intercommunalité il n'en est pas de
même dans un certain nombre
d'intercommunalités nous étions dans la
Somme ou deux des intercommunalités font
plus de 100 communes le Pays Basque 158
communes en Haute-Garonne 144 communes
autant d'intercommunalités ou on voit
qu'il est difficile quand bien même ça
se passe bien parce que l'exemple que
j'évoquais dans la Somme 119 commun ça a
été une intercommunalité choisie c'est à
dire qu'il n'y a pas eu passé outre du
préfet
même si aujourd'hui ce qui est compliqué
c'est qu'il n'y a pas nécessairement de
centralité puisque la plus grande des
communes fait moins de 2500 habitants
donc c'est pas forcément toujours
toujours ça mais on sent que le fait
d'avoir été choisi et partagez le projet
de territoire est un peu plus simple à
écrire il n'en demeure pas moins que ça
n'est jamais aisé d'avoir des conseils
communautaires où on a plus de 150
conseillés communautaires et c'est vrai
que c'est particulièrement dans ce type
d'intercommunalité où on constate qu'il
y a des difficultés parce que elles sont
souvent la résultante de passer outre
elles sont souvent le mariage de
plusieurs territoires de plusieurs
bassins de vie qui n'ont pas
nécessairement cultivé une forme
d'affection sociétative donc c'est
difficile tu es dans une autre
intercommunalité de la Somme j'appuie
mon propos sur quelques exemples on a
une problématique d'un côté littoral de
l'autre où on est plutôt sur de l'hyper
ruralité donc on voit qu'il est pas
toujours aisé de partager de façon quasi
unanime un projet de territoire et on a
c'est le cas du Morbihan aujourd'hui une
intercommunalité qui s'interroge qui a
même fait part d'une volonté de d'être
scindé en deux
si on partage le propos qui consiste à
dire il ne s'agit pas et d'ailleurs on
l'a dit écrit de réinterroger les
périmètres des intercommunalités est-ce
qu'on peut quand même imaginer le faire
à la marge très à la marge quand on
constate qu'il y a vraiment un
dysfonctionnement majeur et que les élus
l'expriment eux-mêmes c'est-à-dire que
c'est pas une volonté de l'État parce
que s'il y a bien une partie du propos
que nous pouvons partager que nous avons
exprimé c'est que pour le maire comme
pour le président intercommunalité
l'accès comme je le disais
au service de l'État à l'ingénierie de
l'État aux dotation de l'État devient de
plus en plus complexe encore une fois
nous l'évoquions tout à l'heure avec la
avec la DGCL et donc il y a une
nécessité effectivement de pas revisiter
de pas modifier la règle la loi parce
que aujourd'hui je crois qu'il est aussi
admis une volonté de garder une forme de
Constance sur le règlement et sur
l'aspect législative mais le cas échéant
est-ce qu'à la marge c'est quelque chose
que vous pouvez admettre après on a un
deuxième un deuxième sujet c'est il
n'est du principe de différenciation
territoriale là encore je prends un
exemple on a
des communautés d'agglomération et je
prends volontairement l'exemple de la
communauté d'agglomération parce que
c'est peut-être le modèle qui offre un
éventail le plus large on peut avoir des
modèles qui sont très urbains
relativement
j'allais dire voire très intégré en
termes de compétences et dans lesquelles
par exemple la compétence mobilité
s'impose d'elle-même et puis des
territoires moi j'ai dans mon
département à la communauté
d'agglomération de Privas une centralité
de 8300 habitants 44 communes sur un
territoire qui est immense avec relief
avec un territoire de vallée où on voit
que c'est plus compliqué de construire
et on sent on l'a observé dans d'autres
territoires est-ce que selon vous on
peut sans nécessairement encore une fois
revenir sur sur le modèle et je le dis à
l'envie parce que très souvent avec
votre Président on a échangé et on veut
surtout pas donner le sentiment qu'ici
au Sénat on est là pour pour découdre
mais on est là pour je pense adapter les
choses et faire en sorte qu'il y ait une
véritable prise en compte de cette
différenciation territoriale de ces
différents cas de figure et encore une
fois je fais bien les propos qui
consistent à dire que à chaque
territoire sa propre sa propre vérité
mais là encore est-ce qu'il y a selon
vous une possibilité notamment avec le
pacte de gouvernance de revisiter un peu
l'exercice de certaines compétences
quitte à imaginer dans le temps pouvoir
les faire redescendre quand on a
notamment des territoires immenses à un
échange proximité voir les faire
remonter parce qu'on a été sur cette
mission largement interpellée par
exemple sur la question de la compétence
gemapi c'est des compétences gymapi de
plus en plus d'intercommunalités nous
disent pour nous ça devient très
compliqué soit parce qu'on est déjà au
taquet de la taxe et qu'on a des
territoires qui sont au pire difficulté
en matière notamment de gestion des
inondations et donc s'interroger sur sur
un modèle éventuellement vers un
département vers un établissement public
de bassin donc voilà faire un petit peu
du coup humain si j'ose dire mais encore
une fois sans nécessairement avoir à
retoucher
à l'ensemble de l'arsenal législatif et
puis peut-être un dernier point un peu
plus un peu plus prospective
ça fait écho un élément qui évoqué
notamment par rapport à la question des
secrétaires mairie notamment où on voit
bien qu'aujourd'hui les conditions
d'exercice des mandats locaux c'est vrai
pour l'intercommunalité mais c'est
encore un peu plus vrai pour ceux des
maires qui préside au destinées des plus
petites communes quand on voit la
difficulté que c'est non pas de recruter
mais de trouver le moyen humain est-ce
que finalement l'intercommunalité alors
la réponse a été partiellement faite
mais c'est pas finalement la continuité
on a eu quelques territoires je pense
notamment à Saint-Malo Haguenau
aujourd'hui les communautés d'agglo par
exemple recrutent un pôle de secrétaire
qu'elle ces communautés avec loin
spécialisent même ces secrétaires pour
qu'il y ait à la fois une forme
d'ingénierie pour être fine spécialiste
sur la question des finances des
ressources humaines ou des sujets liés à
l'urbanisme parce que ça aussi c'est un
des points qui qui remonte fortement
donc est-ce que c'est aussi ce lien qui
qu'il faut nourrir
entre communes intercommunalités en
termes de mutualisation pour que
l'intercommunalité soit la réponse utile
aux devenir de de la mairie et surtout
des conditions d'exercices de ces
mandats locaux qui parfois posent
problème pour pour beaucoup de des mères
que nous avons pu auditionner
beaucoup de sujets merci présidente
beaucoup de sujets sur le rapporteur sur
la différenciation il y a déjà des
choses qui il y a beaucoup de choses qui
existent donc nous on est très favorable
à la différence on veut juste simplement
pas réintroduire trop de concurrents
sans rentrer les uns les autres donc il
faut avec la main tremblante entre
guillemets peut-être le faire la marge
mais c'est vrai que les situations sont
très tellement variées et vous avez
donné un certain nombre d'exemples sur
l'ensemble du territoire national ou ce
qui est vrai d'un côté et pas forcément
vrai de l'autre et donc de permettre à
partir du moment que c'est le choix des
élus de faire ou de défaire à la marge
certaines choses pourquoi pas mais là
pour le coup il faudrait peut-être qu'il
y ait de la part des élus un niveau de
d'acceptation d'une règle je sais pas si
c'est des entière ou mais je crois que
c'est important d'introduire qui est une
vraie volonté que ce soit pas un acte
politique parce qu'il peut avoir des
actes politiques de certaines communes
qui se qui se montent face à on va dire
aux communes qui qui sont dans
l'exécutif intercommunal donc je pense
que si ça se fait ça doit se faire bien
entendu avec le soutien d'une large
majorité du conseil communautaire et au
minima de la conférence des maires qui
qui doit s'exprimer sur le sujet parce
que pour le coup ça les concerne
vraiment au même titre vous avez parlé
de grandes intercos qui imaginent de
pouvoir se séparer pour devenir un
modèle un peu plus de proximité je pense
que la loi le permet
en théorie en pratique c'était compliqué
alors faut peut-être voir comment il y a
peut-être des choses à améliorer parce
que c'est un peu comme les communes
nouvelles on se marie peu pensent qu'on
peut se démarrer mais en fait c'est
possible enfin tu vois que l'État veut
bien jouer ce rôle là aussi parce que on
sait que le rôle du préfet reste quand
même relativement important mais
peut-être de regarder cette possibilité
là mais là au même titre que sur les
compétences la différenciation je pense
que si et ça doit être l'esprit à chaque
fois des élus locaux s'il y a un accord
local
j'ai presque dire il faut pas forcément
s'interdire de de de
faire quelque chose changement si c'est
nécessaire suivant les territoires dans
lequel on se trouve mais sans aller
jusqu'à revenir sur des compétences
anciennes bien ancré dans nos
territoires et qui chamboulerait une
nouvelle fois la structuration des
intercommunalités qui souvent je pense
il y aurait plus profit des communes les
plus importantes et souvent au détriment
à terme quand même au plus petites
communes de l'interco qui aurait pu les
moyens mais sur la mutualisation et
c'est vrai que il faut en fait c'est
vraiment la liberté qu'il faut des fois
on a l'impression que il nous manque un
peu de liberté dans l'écriture quand on
prend une compétence on a l'impression
que des fois enfin je vais prendre
l'exemple de la compétence informatique
qui avait été prise on se rend compte
qu'en fin de compte il y a tellement
tout dedans qu'on peut pas tout gérer et
qu'il faut redonner de la souplesse mais
réécrire dans la compétence qui était
prise ce qui relève de la compétence et
ce qui va relever de la mutualisation en
droit c'est très compliqué
c'est même presque un faisable et ça ça
pose un problème parce que ce qui est
vrai sur la cyber ce qui est vrai sur
sur la gestion éventuellement du
quotidien je prends l'exemple de
l'informatique je suis sur ce sujet donc
je me rends compte de la difficulté sur
la gestion du parc informatique pour
commune au lieu de que chacun paye une
entreprise qui vienne bon mais à côté de
ça de laisser la liberté de pouvoir
prendre des des
outils informatiques des logiciels
propres à chaque commune bah c'est
compliqué de faire cette différenciation
parce que la réglementation nous permet
pas vraiment ou en tout cas il y a des
doutes sur cette possibilité là alors ça
fait de bonheur des avocats spécialisé
dans dans les collectivités mais
peut-être qu'il faut parfois rendre plus
simple plus lisible les possibilités de
différenciation enfin je sais pas si par
exemple le cycle de l'eau si on prend le
cycle de l'eau les agglos on le cycle de
l'eau complet demain la gemapi c'est
vrai qu'il peut poser problème notamment
pour les intercommunalités les plus en
amont qui ont souvent le plus de
kilomètres de de petites rivières de
petits ruisseaux et qui souvent
participent énormément pour protéger
ceux qui sont carnaval qui sont très
souvent des grosses communes puisqu'on a
un approche voilà on approche la plaine
donc ça où il y a plutôt les grosses
communes et c'est souvent l'interco duo
qui paye majoritairement pour protéger
l'intercommunalité du bas donc peut-être
que la PI devrait relever non pas des
intercours mais peut-être du niveau
départemental ou d'une agence au même
titre qui a d'autres agences
intercommunales ça peut être mais par
exemple là est-ce que dans le cycle de
l'eau bon c'est un vrai sujet depuis
nombreuses années est-ce qu'on réouvre
tout ça ça c'est une question
c'est pour ça que je
[Musique]
c'est la raison pour laquelle il faut
faire attention à chaque fois qu'on
s'interroge parce qu'on peut tout
chambouler des équilibre des fois qui
ont été durement trouvés
voilà donc c'est ça qui est complexe et
le rôle que vous avez au Sénat c'est de
gérer toutes ces complexité complexité
issue de la législation et des
règlements et complexité du à des
territoires tellement différents que
voilà en fait ce serait de la souplesse
qu'il faudrait et pas forcément comme on
habitude de le faire en France quelque
chose d'hyper cadré qui en fin de compte
fait le bonheur
de certaines administrations
départementales dréas DDT préfecture
alors que voilà on recherche plutôt
l'efficacité à chaque fois c'est
rechercher l'efficacité
et l'interco est une bonne taille pour
chercher très souvent sur des sujets
complexes cette efficacité mais il faut
de la souplesse également sur la
différenciation je pense que c'est ces
données de la souplesse à chacun à
s'organiser à partir du moment qu'il y a
une volonté politique de s'organiser sur
les territoires
mais ne pas revenir sur les fondamentaux
parce que là cette fois-ci déjà vous
allez mettre du temps pour convaincre
tout le monde et et je pense qu'il faut
faut savoir être raisonnable mais tout
ce qui n'est pas tranché entre
guillemets il faut rendre assez souple
la possibilité aux intercos de de
mutualiser de prendre une partie
peut-être de compétences non
obligatoires mais pas tous je pense
qu'il faut donner de la souplesse c'est
ce que demande en fait les élus c'est de
la souplesse et qu'on part pas sur des
procédures
complexes qui nous permettent qui nous
font pas bouger en fait et qui qui font
qu'on
un mandat de 6 ans devient très court
parce qu'on n'a pas pu faire évoluer
dans votre dans votre département les
collectivités
soutiennent par des politiques
contractuelles
alors les communes
bien sûr il y a des politiques
contractuelles des grandes collectivités
Région Département vous avez quel type
de le département du Rhône soutient à
une politique en direction ce qu'on
appelle le pacte Rhône en direction des
intercommunalités donc il y a des
financements et c'est des intercos qui
choisissent le projet qui souhaitait de
soutenu financièrement donc là il y a
des ratios qui sont faits suivants les
intercos plus ou moins riches parce
qu'on a aussi celles qui sont très
proches de Lyon qui sont un peu plus
riches que celles qui sont au nord du
département
le département aide également les
communes avec chaque année à la main des
conseillers départementaux une somme
pour soutenir les projets
d'investissement de chaque commune des
du département donc là c'est important
pour c'est vraiment un effet levier et
ensuite il y a des intercos comme la
mienne qui qui des fonds de concours en
direction des communes c'est dans le
cadre du pacte financier dans le cadre
du pack de gouvernance
on essaye sur des thématiques nous notre
projet de territoire un fil rouge mais
comme beaucoup sur la transition
énergétique donc on essaye d'aider les
projets des communes qui vont dans ce
sens-là alors c'est pas des sommes elles
sont bien moins importantes que celles
que peut donner le département mais
voilà en tout cas le département a eu
une volonté par un point d'Interco de
réunir une fois patrimoine tous les
présidents d'intercaux il y en a 13 sur
le département du Rhône aujourd'hui
puisque la métropole statue particulier
sont réunis au département avec des
thématiques où l'on discute des des
sujets liés à l'intercommunalité et qui
sont les sujets aussi liés aux communes
à chaque fois d'ailleurs la plupart des
présidents d'intercommunalités sont des
maires et sur le rôle aujourd'hui il y a
plus de maire de très grosses communes
comme par le passé donc on est tous à
peu près du même niveau puis ensuite on
a la chance d'être sur ou là aussi il y
a une forte aide de la part de la région
dans le cadre de contrats liés
aux communes et à l'intercommunalité
également donc ça c'est c'est un plus
indéniable surtout que ce sont les élus
régionaux des départements respectifs
qui qui ont un peu la main là-dessus en
tout cas qui nous aide donc c'est vrai
qu'on essaye d'avoir de la proximité
malgré qu'il y a une très grande région
également on parlait tout à l'heure des
grandes intercos c'est pareil pour les
grandes régions ensuite l'interco a fait
beaucoup dans le cadre du CRPE puisque
là aussi il fallait faire ce contrat
avec l'État moi j'ai refusé de
déterminer quels étaient les projets
prioritaires des communes je considère
que c'était pas au président de
l'intercommunalité de choisir pour le
compte des communes parce que justement
j'ai une élection indirecte et que je
suis que le représentant des communes
donc le CRPE il y a eu de la part de
l'État une volonté de dire mais il va
falloir donner priorité sur l'ensemble
des projets de l'interco mais aussi des
communes membres
quelle est enfin pour ma part je
conseille donc là on revient sur la
gouvernance c'est de dire moi j'ai
plutôt demandé à chaque merde de dire
dans tout ce que tu as proposé il va
falloir quand même mettre une des
priorités et avancer ce qu'on a pu faire
donc on a pu faire un CRPE qui convient
à l'ensemble des communes de mon
intercommunalité mais là une fois de
plus il y a des choses qui peuvent pas
relever de la loi c'est de la bonne
pratique entre guillemets et moi pour
moi l'interco l'intercommunalité c'est
aussi la bonne pratique
peut-être par rapport à ça et et en écho
à la question de la au sujet sur évoqué
sur la souplesse
on l'a vu d'ailleurs ça a été un vrai
sujet dans le 3DS sur un sur une
question chère à ma collègue Françoise
Gatel
ce qu'on a appelé l'amendement nid de
poule qui concerne les intercommunalités
qui ont la voirie parce que c'est
finalement l'exemple type où on a
parfois
la gestion d'une compétence à un échelon
supra communal avec un sujet typiquement
sur la voirie ou l'entretien de la
voirie qui peut relever de la proximité
et parfois la complexité à gérer avec
agilité ce type de compétences et on
voit bien la difficulté souvenir d'un
échange que nous avions eu avec la
ministre Jacqueline Gourault à l'époque
pour essayer de trouver un biais qui
permettrait justement dans une
compétence transférée à
l'intercommunalité voir la capacité
d'intervenir à l'échelon communal pour
justement
avoir cette efficacité et cette
réactivité on voit bien toute la
difficulté aujourd'hui de l'exercice
entre
l'exercice de la compétence et le fait
d'avoir justement
à apprendre en compte cette c'est cette
compétence ça c'est le premier point
deuxième
c'est un sujet qui a été posé
lors de notamment du rendu du dernier
rapport de de la Cour des comptes
un sujet qui est souvent abordé par par
les maires voir les présidents
d'intercommunalité qui est celui de la
principale des dotations qu'il a des GF
quel est votre regard par rapport à ce
sujet faut-il que cette DGF et choix aux
intercommunalités ou aux communes et je
m'empresse de dire que ça n'est
absolument pas pour moi une façon de le
poser de façon polémique mais
c'est un sujet qui est important parce
que c'est la dotation qui permet
véritablement aux communes aujourd'hui
de fonctionner quand bien même celle-ci
est en forte diminution dans nombre de
communes et puis le troisième point
c'est un sujet que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure c'est les relations avec l'État
c'est un des sujets majeurs je
l'évoquais alors autant pour les mères
que les présidents d'intercommunalité on
a beaucoup parlé la dernière fois en
auditionnant les présidents de
départements qui sont aussi des acteurs
et qui accompagnent les
intercommunalités ça vient d'être dit et
les communes
avec Claude Riboulet le président du
département de l'Allier de la question
de la territorialisation de l'action
publique comprendre par là la capacité
que nous aurions à organiser entre les
collectivités
l'état des concentrés et l'État
territorial préfet sous préfet l'action
publique est par la même de prendre en
compte certaines différenciations
beaucoup de d'élus maires présidents
d'intercommunalité regrette parfois la
rigidité demande à la fois une présence
de cet état territorial on regrettant
qu'on soit passé avec le temps d'un état
accompagnateur qui avait les moyens
d'accompagner à un état censeur qui ne
cesse finalement de rigidifier et ses
process et ses dotations prenez
l'exemple notamment de la multiplication
des dotations des cils des TR fond vert
à plan de nos vœux peut-être une
réflexion autour de
de l'uniformisation de l'ensemble de ces
dotations non pas pour le plaisir d'être
uniformisé mais parce que ça permet un
peu plus d'agilité ça permet de moins
sectoriser de moins segmenter le c'est
ces enveloppes et surtout d'être plus
réactif parce que à chacune de ces
dotations
je veux dire une accès différencié des
conditions d'éligibilité qui ne sont
tout autant et donc tout ça rend quand
même
je vais dire le CET axé finalement au
service et au moyen de l'État que
beaucoup d'élus communaux comme
intercommunaux
dénoncent considérant qu'on a là une
forme d'inertie qui est préjudiciable
dans un temps où on a besoin d'agilité
on a besoin de réactivité singulièrement
après les différentes crises que nous
venons de vivre par rapport à la
commande publique par rapport à
l'économie sur sur chacun de nos
territoires et donc la capacité à aller
vite et
aussi cette question d'ingénierie qui
est qui se pose pour nombre la
communalité considérant qu'elles ne sont
pas toutes
dotées de moyens et d'un nombre
d'habitants qui leur permettent de
générer des moyens de fonctionnement
suffisants pour répondre notamment à la
politique d'appel à projet du territoire
donc avoir un peu votre votre regard là
dessus peut-être avec un vision un peu
prospective c'est-à-dire comment vous
voyez demain les relations
intercommunalité
et service de l'État sur sur les
territoires voilà j'ai été beaucoup trop
long mais si on peut avoir quelques
réponses sur ces sur ces trois sujets
alors sur la compétence voirie parce que
c'est le sujet qui avait été abordé
alors moi je vais parler de ce que je
connais sur la compétence varie j'ai de
la voirie d'intérêt communautaire et de
la voirie qui reste purement communale
et en ce qui concerne la voirie
d'intérêt communautaire j'avais pas créé
un service propre de gestion du
quotidien de cette varie
intercommunautaire
communautaire plutôt donc on a passé des
accords avec les communes et en rémunère
les communes pour l'entretien
c'est-à-dire qu'on a pris le nombre de
kilomètres on a fait un coût moyen de de
gestion de du quotidien il y a
pointe à temps tout et on leur donne ses
moyens pour être le plus efficace
possible alors je présume que ça peut
être la même chose si la compétence
varie est totalement donné à l'interco
je pense qu'il y a une possibilité au
quotidien de pouvoir déléguer
la gestion de ce service aux communes en
rémunérant bien sûr c'est normal interco
après la compétence rémunéré
l'investissement c'est plus simple mais
sur le fonctionnement rémunéré des
communes pour qu'elles gèrent le
fonctionnement alors je sais pas quelle
est la pratique généralement mais
c'est des voiries on a défini l'intérêt
communautaire par exemple toutes les
voiries qui vont sur les écoles la
mairie qui sont pas départementales sont
devenus des voiries d'intérêts
communautaires sur une salle des sports
tout ce qui est lié ou une voirie qui va
entre deux départementales importantes
on a déterminé tout ça d'un commun
accord avec l'ensemble des mers c'est un
gros travail et ensuite on a fait un
calcul de combien coûte
traditionnellement quand il y a du
déneigement quand le balayage voilà et
on rémunère
on verse une somme aux communes par
rapport au kilomètre qu'ils ont de
voirie d'intérêt communautaire
vous connaissez pas en fait les
communautés de communes qu'on connaît
dans notre entourage et qui ont qui ont
pris cette compétence selon énormément
regretté parce que c'est un gouffre
financier pour les communes et pour les
intercos
cette idée là du conventionnement entre
l'interco et les communes vont s'y
intéressante en tout cas pour la
communauté de communes pour autant si on
devait prendre d'une façon plus élargie
la compétence je pense que c'est là qui
aurait des économies d'échelle à mon
avis à faire parce que si chaque commune
entretient sa voirie et se fait par
convention remboursée par la Communauté
de Communes ça me paraît très très
coûteux mais je pense que c'est vraiment
une compétence qui est extrêmement
pesante et j'ai vu une communauté de
communes notamment qui a renoncé à cette
compétence qui l'a rendu aux communes
après mais c'est clair que ça chiffre
très vite de gérer surtout qu'en milieu
rural ou les voiries sont très très
importantes sur des grandes longueurs
mais même en centre-ville parce que
après il y a la partie voirie il y a les
trottoirs il y a tout ce qui va autour
de la voirie en tout cas nous c'est le
choix qu'on a fait et là aussi un peu
c'est la liberté et que quand on parlait
tout à l'heure qui a toute son
importance
après en mutualise pour les voiries
communales au même titre qu'on le fait
pour l'avoirie internet on passe un
marché global l'ensemble des communes
pour avoir justement des prix auprès de
nos prestataires c'est c'est
important de d'avoir cette possibilité
là de de faire des appels d'offres
communs sur sur la voirie par exemple
c'est le cas
le sens de ma question
parce que j'ai été aussi présent
intercommunalité et en réalité c'est
vrai que le sujet se pose moins sur les
communautés d'agglomération et sur les
communautés de communes parce qu'on a
justement c'est encore cette agilité
l'exemple de du fameux amendement nid de
poules y en est plutôt les métropoles et
les communautés urbaines et l'exemple
en réalité ne visait pas simplement à
parler de la seule compétence voirie
mais de se dévoquer la difficulté de
mettre de la souplesse entre les jetons
communales élection et la strate
intercommunale dès lors voilà qu'on a
transféré la compétence
ah oui le grand sa priori on a eu cet
exemple là
il faut que chacun cherche un peu
en fait c'est le quotidien c'est la
pratique qui fait que voilà et pour le
coup votre mission est particulièrement
importante parce que ça vous permet
d'aller voir toutes les tout ce qui se
fait un peu de partout sur le territoire
national et ça je pense que ça va être
un rapport très intéressant pour pour
voir ce qu'on prend l'exemple aussi sur
les autres parfois on se dit tiens
comment on va gérer ça
d'où la question et c'est la question
suivante c'est qu'on a le sentiment
aussi de plus en plus que
c'est une question que nous posions tout
à l'heure à la DGCL que malheureusement
l'esprit
des services de l'État à la lecture du
des évolutions législatives à parfois
derrière des écueils qui sont l'absence
de décret d'application parfois
certains services de l'État a commencé
par la DGCL jusqu'à l'état territorial
préfet sous préfet une petite tendance à
avoir une lecture
je dirais pas orientée mais en tout cas
à l'homme des problématiques de chacun
des territoires et c'est ce qui est un
peu ce qui rend un peu l'exercice
compliqué et donc qui fait que on a
selon les différents territoires les
différentes départements des cas
d'espèces et des cas de figure qui
peuvent être très différenciées la
volonté qu'on a aussi c'est le message
qu'on a fait passer tout à l'heure à
l'état ce qu'on a fait avec la démat ce
qu'on a qu'on fera avec le avec le
ministre c'est vraiment la volonté de
dire que bien sûr il y a ce principe de
différenciation mais il est important
quand même que les assouplissements que
tout ce qu'on peut essayer de faire
évoluer à la marche encore une fois sans
remettre en compte
l'architecture permettre quand même cet
assouplissement qui est quand même assez
compliqué dans la dans la philosophie de
l'État y compris des préfets ou sous
préfet qui sont pour le coup
cette plébiscité parce que beaucoup plus
à l'écoute des mères des présidents
d'intercommunalités mais on sent encore
qu'à cette rigidité qui fait que trop
souvent
on va attaquer je veux dire un arrêté on
va on va remettre en cause une
délibération parce que on considère que
justement elle contrevient alors que
l'esprit du législateur c'est justement
de permettre et d'admettre cette cette
souplesse pour ça que je parlais
volontairement de ce point qui est pour
nous essentiel de la relation du bloc
communal pour arrêter de dire
communalité avec ce service de l'État
rapidement sur la deuxième question qui
était sur la DGF on n'a pas de position
de l'interco sur la DGF j'ai un problème
de la DGF c'est avant tout de savoir
comment elle est calculée
parce que si quelqu'un peut me dire
comment c'est calculer quand on voit des
différences qui les communes notamment
ou parfois on se demande pourquoi il y a
une telle différence c'est un peu comme
la fiscalité locale le problème
aujourd'hui c'est les basses fiscales
qui correspondent plus à la réalité donc
avant de se poser la question de savoir
s'il y a des élèves doit aller à
l'interco ou au rester aux communes je
pense qu'il faut déjà peut-être voir le
calcul la cohérence dans le calcul de la
DGF parce qu'on a beau nous dire que il
y a un certain nombre de choses qui sont
pris en compte pour déterminer la DGF
moi je me suis amusé à regarder sur le
département du Rhône les différences
parfois notable et je me dis
qu'est-ce qui peut faire cette
différence notable pour une commune
presque équivalente
enfin je sais pas si c'est un sujet que
vous abordez de la DGF mais voilà donc
voilà
déjà une baisse conséquente
[Musique]
j'allais dire que la DGF est quand même
là pour
pour permettre aux communes et aux
maires d'exercer au nom de l'État un
certain nombre de prérogatives
pour ceux qui n'ont plus de DGF
pourraient se poser des questions se
dire mais en fin de compte est-ce qu'on
exerce encore pour le compte de l'État
parce que je suis pas rémunéré pour
mais ça peut être un sujet en tout cas
en tout cas il y a plus d'autonomie
financière tout à fait et l'autonomie
financière est un vrai souci majeur et
ça va me permettre justement de partir
sur les relations entre
le bloc communal et et les services de
l'État
j'allais dire heureusement que parfois
on a encore des sous-préfet et des
préfets qui essayent de mettre de
l'huile dans les rouages et et surtout
essaye parfois d'être de mettre d'accord
une administration
départementale voie régionale parfois en
contradiction entre eux entre elles
c'est un vrai sujet on le voit sur
un certain nombre de de de de dossier
j'en tête un dossier urbanistique ou la
DDT était en désaccord avec la police de
l'eau certains nous demandaient de de de
de de de mettre un peu plus de terre à
un certain niveau les autres nous
disaient non non ça va engendrer des
inondations bon là on était obligé de
faire intervenir de préfet donc le
préfet un vrai rôle parce qu'on peut
regretter c'est vraiment
l'administration locale et les services
de la DDT de l'adréal qui est
aujourd'hui suivant l'état dans lequel
on se trouve font des lectures parfois
très strictes de réglementation ou
anticipe même certains décrets
d'applications qui sont pas passés alors
que voilà ils sont pas en mesure de de
le faire donc on se demande parfois si
c'est pas le positionnement de la
personne qui a la tête de ce service qui
fait la réglementation si c'est vraiment
la réglementation qui est appliquée
parce que les élus par l'entre eux
surtout quand on est limitrophes avec
d'autres départements et des fois on se
rend compte que sur le même cas pratique
il y a une décision de l'État qui est
différente ce qui est quand même
compliqué au bout d'un moment donc là je
pense qu'il faut aussi et là c'est le
rôle des associations d'élus c'est le
rôle du Sénat bien entendu de de de
vraiment travailler ce sujet avec avec
l'État qui centralise et vous avez parlé
l'état censeur
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui on nous dit
plus souvent non que oui
j'ai un exemple d'un vieux sous préfet
qui avait relu une lettre du ministre de
l'Intérieur dans les années 30 où il
disait au sous-préfet et au préfet et en
gros il disait bah voilà il faut que
vous cherchiez toujours des solutions
aux côtés de vos élus et si vous trouvez
pas de solution ou si vous êtes obligé
de dire non expliquer pourquoi
maintenant j'ai l'impression qu'on nous
dit non on sait pas vraiment pourquoi
je force un peu le trait mais peu
donc là je pense que l'État se doit
aussi
de de
comment dire de
redonner au préfet un peu de pouvoir sur
une administration sur leur propre
administration de chef de service ou
autre qui ont des fois pris le dessus de
la responsabilité qui avait à l'époque
les préfets les sous-préfets qui étaient
là pour siffler la fin de la partie et
dire il faut qu'on avance je pense que
ça c'est c'est très important sur les
dotations de l'État et vous l'avez dit
la sénatrice
aujourd'hui
les collectivités
sont très dépendantes des dotations de
l'État sur leur fonctionnement
donc
c'est plus difficile de contester de
montrer son désaccord parce qu'on se dit
tiens on va être sanctionné parce que la
DSI elle la D le fond vert je vais pas
en avoir parce que j'étais un peu j'ai
un peu remonté les bretelles à mon
préfet ou Adriel ou la DDT quand on
avait un peu d'autonomie financière ça
donnait aussi un peu d'autonomie pour
dire des choses aujourd'hui on est
tellement dépendant des notations de
l'État et c'est discrétionnel et ses
discrétionnaire parce que pour avoir été
parlementaire à l'époque où il y avait
la réserve parlementaire en nous disait
que c'était discrétionnaire mais
j'aimerais savoir sur quel critères
parfois sont donnés subventions au
niveau de l'État l'avantage d'un député
ou d'un sénateur c'est que au bout d'une
certaine période il peut être
éventuellement remercié pour ce qui est
rare à d'autres niveaux donc voilà sur
la DCL la dotr et le fond vert on s'y
perd un peu parce qu'à chaque fois on
nous dit il faut aller sur actuellement
c'est sur elle est sur les économies
d'énergie voilà on se dit on se dépose
un detot en dit non mais c'est plutôt la
DS et puis maintenant il y a le fond
vert et puis si vous demandez il faut
justifier que l'investissement que vous
allez faire sur votre bâtiment de
l'école que vous allez rénover que vous
êtes bien moins 30%
d'économies d'énergie pourquoi pas ce
qui est assez logique il faut bien faire
les travaux pour économiser mais on
retrouve des petites communes qui
avaient peu de moyens ou des petites
intercommunalités qui avaient peu de
moyens qui font qui avait commencé à
faire quelques travaux à changer les
fenêtres et qui au moment de déposer le
dossier deux ans plus tard on leur dit
ben non vous faites pas moins de 30% bah
oui bien sûr on a déjà débuté il y a
déjà deux trois ans mais bon comme on a
peu de moyens parce qu'on a de moins en
moins de moyens bah on fait ça en
plusieurs projets donc là aussi c'est
une difficulté et là l'interco vient en
aide en termes d'ingénierie parce que
sinon les communes ne seraient pas faire
elle sera obligé de passer par des
prestataires privés
qui sont qui se rémunèrent quand même
bien et là l'interco ou ce qui est le
cas sur des départements du Rhône on a
une association départementale où
l'interco et le département sont membres
finances et qui interviennent pour le
compte des communes gratuitement pour
faire ce genre de relevé mais voilà
c'est une vraie difficulté mais les
relations entre l'État et le blog
communal c'est vrai sont moins fluides
que par le passé alors pas au niveau des
sous préfets généralement ça se passe
plutôt bien et heureusement qu'on a
encore sur le territoire enfin en tout
cas c'est mon avis des sous-préfets
d'arrondissement mais si je prends
l'exemple de la DDT
pas plus tard qu'hier une réunion sur le
Scott du Beaujolais
on a une représentante de la DDT qui
considérait par exemple on n'est pas
pris assez en compte
l'agriculture et la viticulture alors
qu'on venait d'avoir le l'intervention
du président de la chambre de
l'agriculture et le président de
l'interogec qui disait vraiment vous
avez vraiment pris en compte ce qu'on
vous demandait voilà donc
cette dame qui est aujourd'hui est à
Lyon je suis pas sûr qu'elle connaissait
bien le territoire à l'époque il y avait
des subdivisions les subdivisions
subdivisionnaires étaient sur chaque
chef-lieu de canton on peut peut-être
voir ça au niveau
intercommunal mais il connaissait son
territoire parce qu'ils vivaient
aujourd'hui on a plus ça donc on est sur
uniquement de la théorie et on est plus
sur la pratique et on se bat au
quotidien quand on est maire ou quand on
est président d'intercommunalité pour
faire venir sur le territoire
l'administration qui vient de vous dire
non faut dire venez voir
ça aussi c'est c'est une difficulté et
ce qui peut engendrer chez les maires de
la frustration parce que le maire d'une
plus petite commune qui ne cumule pas de
mandat qui a un poids politique assez
faible il n'y arrive pas ça aussi c'est
un malaise chez les maires
quand on cumule bon ça permet d'avoir un
poids un peu plus important au niveau
départemental mais mais réellement c'est
je pense que tout ça frustre beaucoup
également les élus locaux qui ne
comprennent pas souvent des décisions
qui sont négatives et on leur explique
pas pour quelle raison il peut avoir
parfois des bonnes raisons on n'est pas
en train de dire qu'il faut dire oui et
tout mais je pense que voilà
l'administration doit aussi se réformer
au niveau local c'est certain si on veut
redonner aussi un peu de passion en mer
qui a envie de faire les présidents
aussi ont envie de faire même si les
moyens sont plus faibles pour la plupart
même si d'autres se portent mieux et des
communes plus riches des interco plus
riches mais mais quand on veut faire et
qu'on est particulièrement restreint
dans la volonté de faire pour des choses
qui peuvent paraître parfois quand même
exagérées qui relève même plus de
l'esprit de la loi plus de l'esprit de
celui qui veut faire appliquer ce qu'ils
pensent être sa position je suis un peu
dur là-dessus mais réellement c'est un
peu ce qu'on vit parfois
[Musique]
très bien
merci beaucoup monsieur
le sens des auditions que nous avons eu
jusque là en fait sous s'appelait en
faveur d'une proximité qui
malheureusement disparaît parce qu'il y
a aujourd'hui une recentralisation et
depuis tellement d'années donc c'est
bien d'être le porte-parole de tout ça
et vraiment je le redis moi je vois pas
le rôle de la commune sans le rôle de
l'intercommunalité enfin le bloc
communal est Matthieu je crois que quand
tu as parlé de blog communal oui c'est
le blog communal les deux vont ensemble
j'ai une dernière question justement
enfin d'un sujet sur lequel on s'est
largement interrogé qui est pour moi une
énigme parce que c'est quelque chose
qu'on utilise très peu et qui d'ailleurs
pourrait permettre au sein des
intercommunalités ou même entre commune
d'avancer sur certains points qui sont
infras communautaire c'est la question
de la convention je trouve qu'on
conventionne très peu c'est un outil et
on ne cesse de le dire mais des fois on
a vraiment des problématiques au sein
d'un périmètre intercommunal pour gérer
espace vert pour gérer pour acheter du
matériel en commun et construire un pont
pour que nous avons fait pour pour gérer
un équipement infrac ou
l'intercommunalité n'a pas envie d'aller
parce que ça n'a pas de sens ou
l'interco ou la commune est trop petite
pour porter
et et je trouve sincèrement et je le dis
à la plupart des associations d'élus de
la plus grande à la plus petite des mers
euros jusqu'à France urbaine qu'on
utilise assez peu en réalité et et je
trouve ça assez dommage parce que je
pense que ça permettrait un peu dans la
droite ligne de ce qu'on évoquait tout à
l'heure à savoir la nécessaire souplesse
qu'il faut laisser peut-être des fois
c'est une des solutions qui n'est pas
assez utilisée et qui permet très
justement de traiter quelques sujets
dont on comprend aisément alors
singulièrement quand vous avez des
grandes intercommunalités je parle même
pas du Pays Basque mais une
intercommunalité à plus de 50 il est
évident qu'on voit pas étendre forcément
une compétence à tout le territoire ou
un service porté par tout le territoire
et en même temps dont on comprend
notamment ça a été le cas avec ce qu'on
a appelé les compétences orphelines
quand des petites intercommunalités sont
mariés avec des très grandes les la très
grande communauté d'agglo ou urbaine ne
voulant pas nécessairement reprendre je
pense notamment compétences
périscolaires
le centre de loisirs et je pense que ça
voilà c'est peut-être quelque chose
qu'il faut qu'on qu'on revisite un peu
parce que trop souvent le on le
méconnait quoi
pas tout à fait dans le sens de la
différenciation chez chacun est
d'ailleurs c'est ce que vous souleviez
tout à l'heure en prenant l'exemple de
la voirie bon après ça se discute pour
les fameuses économies mais c'est vrai
que ça évite de prendre dans l'ensemble
du territoire la même compétence et par
contre quelques fois ponctuellement
vraiment il faut que l'interco soit au
chevet des communes et la convention
c'est très très facile comme outil en
plus c'est une remontée de nos adhérents
sur cette volonté d'utiliser je crois
qu'il y a des conventions plutôt dites
de
allez-y parce que merci
on échange avec nos adhérents
régulièrement il nous semble que sur les
prestations de service et les
conventions qui sont pas mal pratiqué et
comprise dans leur logique ce qui fait
qu'après que la pratique les choses sont
un peu cernées par rapport à ce qu'on
veut en faire et en revanche dans ce qui
concerne les conventions de délégation
de compétences qui sont qui ont été un
peu élargi en plus récemment donc un
temps d'approche de l'outil aussi ou
convention de maîtrise d'ouvrage
délégués genre de choses là c'est vrai
qu'on est sur des choses qui sont moins
bien cernées parfois aussi une hypothèse
c'est que ça vient un peu se heurter à
la logique habituelle du transfert de
compétences qui est quand même notre
carcan habituel et ce qui va avec les
charges transférées qui sont réévalués à
chaque fois par rapport à des choses qui
pourraient être envisagées